Tom good morning how you feeling today i
am doing great glad this series had an
exciting game and got some link to it
down after game for what did you think I
thought Cleveland was clearly in the
driver's seat I mean even with a
pitching Mac that starting pitching
matchup in the favor the cubbies I
didn't like the vibe I was getting from
the Cubs their offenses game was bad
poor that chasing pitches and
Cleveland's pitching especially bullpen
had been wiped out so I actually thought
the game was a little shaky for the Cubs
last night didn't think they're better
that great last night that missed
opportunities attack on run so they're
not out of the woods yet I brought this
up to Bob Costas and I know it may sound
strange but is it is it better for
baseball if the Cubs don't win the World
Series I he revered a lot you know it's
a great narrative hundred eight years
keep it rolling you know something some
collapse or some monumental event that
causes them not to win this year keep
the narrative Don I get it I think this
is truth to that um not a bad story to
see the cubs win a World Series to
because it may never happen if there's
no guarantee this thing gets back again
so they're compelling win or lose and
some people will say even more
compelling losing you got area in Game
six it would feel like that's an
advantage for the Cubs but is it that
much of an advantage in Cleveland I know
I I think jake has not been on point I
think he's been very inefficient fittest
man is just a little bit off and I got
to tell you I've been impressed with
this kid Tomlin because he really
changed the way he threw late the season
the last two months of the season
actually changed the arm slot on his
curveball if you've been watching this
series the Indians are just destroying
the Cubs with curveballs you know they
have pitchers who throw really good ones
when you talk about all three starters
ever-closer curry Allen and I think the
key will be he's probably only to see
Tomlin for two at bats each we talked
about that two times around the lineup
for the Cubs they better have a
after those 18 a bath yeah but I don't
think that enables miss Miller Allen
shots yeah it and we saw that last night
and I thought that you know John Smoltz
and Joe made a great point that if they
didn't get a run in the fourth inning
then they were in trouble because all of
a sudden come fifth inning that's when
Francona is going to go to the bullpen
and then all of a sudden it's been
lights out but I'm curious how much like
we give it a prank own a lot of credit
here with how he's handled his bullpen
but how much credit to managers deserve
her how important our managers come
World Series time as opposed to maybe
managing a team an entire regular season
uh probably more important obviously the
stakes are higher but i think what
carries given work so well because his
players trust them but to attend
implicitly in other words running andrew
miller out there to fifth and income of
a World Series game he can only do that
when the player says all right this must
be the right thing to do and Terry is so
good and engendering trust his guys but
all those guys in the bull pen of great
stuff and they're all okay with coming
in it's something that's outside of
quote-unquote that the traditional role
you know we've got a seventh inning guy
eighth inning guy a nice any guy that
was the Royals last year and Terry's
really flipped that by using any guy at
any time and he's able to do that
because guys by in like okay this must
make sense then all right Mike Napoli's
on the bench tonight and Santana's going
to hit a home run is going to work out
he's going to play left field enough
burners uh and I think Carrie does that
all the things he does before the game
to get the trust of his players whether
it means playing cribbage was Mike
Napoli I just hanging out with the guys
I think that's what makes him a really
good manager he can do unconventional
things and his team completely buys in
tom verducci of Fox Sports Sports
Illustrated joining a stamp Patrick show
that atmosphere at Wrigley Field you
knew they were going to it was going to
be in an atmosphere and in a crazy
atmosphere but living through that I've
having seen that first World Series game
was it what you thought it was going to
be the atmosphere it was Dan because yes
before Game three it was Marty
in the streets for about 11 a.m. in the
morning I'm is Marty grad new years and
all combined together then when they
lost middle of the second game as well
they still weren't hitting it was a
weird dynamic last night and I spoke
with the Anthony Rizzo about this my ask
what was it like playing in this game
with all this tension and he said he
said I almost had a heart attack three
times on the field and he said one thing
that I felt was the nervousness of the
crowd I mean it was a double-edged sword
where they were excited but the same
time they were nervous it was like
Fenway Park free 2004 where you're like
all right when's the other shoe gonna
drop I thought was really interesting
that Rizzo plenty in the game on the
field picked up the nervous energy of
the crowd so it was loud at times and
other times it was purely you know
nerve-racking so I it's really different
dynamic in that Park than anywhere else
and I didn't know if that the atmosphere
added more pressure to the Cubs
understanding what this game men what
this series meant to them you can see
their faces as opposed to being in
Cleveland is there any benefit to the
Cubs being away from wrigley in this
atmosphere I would say the only benefit
as you got Kyle schwarber as a th yeah
the much better line up he's going to
give you better at that atmosphere I
didn't think Cleveland was that loud you
know what things are going well for them
it were but it was really cold in
Cleveland and so it's one of those games
where people have her heavy jackets on
and gloves and you know not one game
that was four hours a lot of them were
leaving school night before it was over
it wasn't as loud as Wrigley Field I
think it will be for game six but I
think Cubs Arabic they won't be they
won't be nervous over a calendar
pressure and Cleveland I think they're
good spot especially I swore ber back
online well safe travels Tom great talk
to you thanks for joining us great stuff
really enjoyed your broadcast right BAM
at Tom Verducci Sports Illustrated Fox
Sports the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you